et que finalement cette journée
nationale contre le harcèlement qui
concerne absolument tous les
établissements mettre fin au harcèlement
scolaire telle est l'objectif de cette
journée des élèves et leurs enseignants
réfléchissent à la question ils se sont
réunis ce jeudi 10 novembre au pôle
Molière des Mureaux à l'issue de cette
journée des élèves ambassadeurs ont été
désignés pour se faire porte-parole de
la lutte contre le harcèlement badenba
est l'un d'entre eux quand j'étais au
collège j'avais des amis qui se
faisaient harceler parce que ils étaient
ils avaient des handicaps et
il se fait harceler pour toi et
n'importe quoi parce que quand il devait
passer au tableau ils avaient pas
compris ou parce qu'ils étaient pas à
fond dans le corps à cause des élèves
qui les harcèdent et du coup ça fait
baisser la moyenne et ils ont mal fini
l'année
l'encadrement scolaire est lui aussi
très actif sur la question enseignant
proviseur conseillé principaux ils sont
nombreux à avoir répondu présent
aujourd'hui je suis là pour mettre en
place des actions contre l'arcement dans
mon lycée
c'est encore à l'état embryonnaire et je
cherche des idées avec mes équipes pour
trouver le moyen d'améliorer la
situation les ambassadeurs sont là
aujourd'hui donc voilà là c'est le c'est
un peu embryonnaire comme on dit là
c'est vraiment on est en train de lancer
avec les élèves et puis après ces
ambassadeurs là donc déjà vont arriver
dans l'établissement avec ce qui a été
travaillé aujourd'hui et puis ensuite on
va les former en tout cas pour au moins
qui est sensibilise
les autres élèves de l'établissement
à 100% des collèges et des lycées de
l'académie de Versailles sont engagés et
50% ont d'ores et déjà
participé au programme de formation donc
on progresse et on a un plan un plan
d'action pour couvrir tout le monde
depuis 2 ans des ateliers de ce type
sont organisés chaque année le
harcèlement scolaire toucherait encore
entre 800 000 et 1 million d'élèves en
France